ردنا على اطلاقه قذائف صاروخيه باتجاه
هضبه الجولان المحتله غارات شنتها القوات
الاسرائيليه على الاراضي السوريه تل ابيب
حددت اهداف هذه الغارات داخل سوريا وبينها
مواقع عسكريه عده في محيط دمشق والقنيطره
شملت مجمعا عسكريا تابعا للفرقه الرابعه
دون انباء عن عصابات المتحدث باسم الجيش
الاسرائيلي اكد ان طائراتهم استهدفت
منظومات رادار مصادر العربيه كشفت ان
الطيران الاسرائيلي استهدف بغاره جويه
موقعا لجماعه مواليه لايران في محيط قريه
ابو قاووق
وسع بيري في دمشق الجنوبيه لاستهدافات
شملت مواقع مدفعيه لقوات النظام وجماعات
ايرانيه بمحيط قريه الكوم وسريه صيدا
الجولان في محافظه
القنيطره اضافه الى سريه عابدين وسريه
معربه الواقعه
بحوض اليرموك
الواقع بقى سوريا وفقا لمصادر العربيه
ياتي ذلك عقد عقب اطلاق ثلاث قدائر
صاروخيه من سوريا نحو هضبه الجولان المحتل
حيث اكد الجيش الاسرائيلي ان اثنتين منها
وقعتها في منطقه مفتوحه وقذيفه اخرى
اعترضت اعترضت من قبل الدفاعات الجويه سبق
ذلك اطلاق اكثر من 30 صاروخ من جنوب لبنان
باتجاه اسرائيل لم تتبناها اي جهه لهذه
العمليه عمليه الاطلاق لكن الجيش
الاسرائيلي قال انها نيران فلسطينيه لا
تلقف ميليشيا حزب الله وراءها
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات